Transcriptor: Jovani Laz
Revisor: Anna Sobota
Buenas tardes a todos.
Cuantas emociones a flor de piel, ¿verdad?
Os imagináis cómo sería la vida
de las personas sin sueños,
sin pasión y sin metas.
Yo no.
No concibo la vida sin ilusiones,
sin obstáculos que sortear
o sin segundos que robarle al tiempo.
Tal vez ese sea el motivo por el que
decidí ser deportista profesional.
Me llamo Vanessa y como acabo de decir,
he sido deportista profesional
más de la mitad de mi vida.
Todo este tiempo
se me ha pasado volando.
Bueno, en mi caso ha sido corriendo.
Normalmente, para explicar lo importante
que es el deporte para mí,
lo suelo hacer a través
del esfuerzo físico.
Digamos que consigo expresar la plenitud
que me aporta el deporte
gracias al sudor de mi cuerpo
o al dolor de mis piernas.
Hoy, voy a intentar transmitir esa fuerza
y esa pasión a través de mis palabras.
Espero encontrar las palabras adecuadas
que hagan que corráis
al interior de mi corazón,
aunque nunca os hayáis calzado
unas zapatillas deportivas.
Que seáis capaces
de sentir en vuestra piel
la emoción con la que voy a hablar
en los próximos minutos.
El deporte es mucho más
que ganar o perder.
Es una escuela que te forma
para conseguir ser
la mejor versión de ti mismo,
cuando te enfrentas a un objetivo nuevo.
Te enseña a transformar tus debilidades
en fortalezas y así seguir creciendo.
Te ayuda a construir tu historia,
a guiar tus pasos por esta vida.
Este ratito hablando para vosotros
es un ejemplo de lo mucho
que aprendí a través del deporte.
Soy una mujer muy tímida
y de pocas palabras.
Para mí supone un esfuerzo muy grande
tener que hablar en público.
Y aquí me tenéis
con las pulsaciones disparadas,
pero convencida de que puedo
transmitir lo que siento.
Me voy a esforzar
en conseguir que este reto,
que nada tiene que ver con
lo que acostumbro hacer,
salga fenomenal.
He dicho millones de veces
que cuando corro un maratón siento
cosas muy parecidas a las que sentí
mientras daba a luz a mis hijos.
Si, no estoy loca.
Comparo el dolor, las contracciones
e incluso la emoción de tener por primera
vez a mis hijos en brazos
con la satisfacción y la grandeza
que se siente al cruzar una línea de meta.
Quizás ese también sea el motivo
por el cual recuerdo con tanto cariño
el nacimiento de mis hijos.
El 23 de mayo del año 2004,
llegué al hospital para
dar a luz a mi hija mayor.
Por aquel entonces, yo tenía 24 años.
Sí, también he corrido para ser madre.
Aquel día estaba muy nerviosa.
Tenía miedo al dolor, a lo desconocido.
Recuerdo que cuando la enfermera,
muy simpática ella, me dijo:
“Enhorabuena, estás de parto.
Quítate la ropa y ponte el camisón”,
pensé en salir corriendo.
Sentí que caminaba al borde de
un precipicio y me caí al vacío.
Me quedé paralizada.
Me senté en un taburete, apoyé
las manos sobre la cabeza
y sin darme cuenta,
como por arte de magia,
empecé a recordar que otras muchas veces
me había sentido así
antes de alguna competición.
Por ejemplo, en mi primer
campeonato del mundo.
Aquel día fue horrible.
Estaba llena de miedos, dudas.
Las piernas me temblaban como hoy.
Como os podéis imaginar,
la carrera fue de pena.
Yo no quería recordar así
el nacimiento de mis hijos.
Así que tras un reseteo rápido
de esos que los deportistas hacemos
antes de alguna gran competición,
me preparé mentalmente
y me puse el camisón.
Aunque al principio pensaba
que eso sería una tortura,
una vez me convencí a mí misma
de que yo podría con ello,
os prometo que disfruté muchísimo.
Eran sensaciones que podía reconocer.
Se parecía mucho a los millones
de entrenamientos que había hecho
y de los cuales había aprendido a manejar
tanto las emociones
como los dolores físicos.
Cada contracción era un paso
adelante, hacia la meta.
En este caso, hacia mi hija.
16 meses después nació mi Julieta,
con las mismas sensaciones
y las mismas emociones.
Unos añitos después, nació David.
Ese niño, tengo que reconocer
que ya salió derrapando.
Era el tercero.
Qué guapo está en la foto, ¿verdad?
Como os estaréis dando cuenta,
no voy a intentar convenceros
de los múltiples beneficios físicos
o psicológicos que tiene el deporte.
Sé que estáis hartos de
escuchárselo a todo el mundo.
En realidad, quiero que recordéis esta
charla desde un punto de vista diferente
y mucho más personal.
Gracias a este deporte, también he tenido
la suerte de conocer al amor de mi vida.
Con Julio, he encontrado
al mejor compañero de viaje.
Juntos hemos formado una preciosa familia.
Nuestros hijos han querido
seguir nuestros pasos
y ese es motivo, más que suficiente,
para que nuestra vida siga
ligada por siempre a este deporte.
Si yo digo tenis, ¿en quién pensáis?
Tranquilos, todavía no puedo
leer las mentes.
Pero es curioso.
Siempre que escucháis
hablar sobre deporte,
a vuestra mente viene la imagen
de un deportista profesional,
alguien que vive por y para el deporte.
Pero en realidad el deporte
va mucho más allá
y está al alcance
de la mano de cualquiera.
Cualquiera de nosotros podemos
aprender y disfrutar de él
sin que éste sea el eje
central de nuestra vida
como sí lo es
de los deportistas profesionales.
Cualquiera de nosotros puede
sentirse un campeón
si pone en práctica todo
lo que está a nuestro alcance
para enriquecer nuestra propia persona
y para superar nuestros pequeños retos,
nuestras metas diarias.
El deporte no lo es todo,
pero con el tiempo te lo explica todo.
Yo me atrevería a decir
que las personas más exitosas, a las que
idolatramos y llamamos genios,
lo son porque son capaces de mezclar
su pasión con un punto de locura.
Mi maestro era un genio.
Algunos pensaban que estaba loco.
Su locura me llevó a hacer
realidad muchos sueños.
Solía decir que el cuerpo humano no tiene
límites, que tenía que trabajar y confiar.
Así lo hice y así fui creciendo como
persona y como deportista.
Cosechando éxitos a la vez que iba
construyendo unos pilares fuertes
en mi peculiar carrera de ultrafondo.
El año 2012 fue muy especial para mí.
Ese año, pude hacer realidad
mi mayor sueño deportivo.
Ese 5 de agosto del 2012,
fui la primera mamá de familia numerosa
que en mi deporte, el atletismo,
representaba a España
en unos Juegos Olímpicos.
Nunca antes una mujer con tantos hijos
había podido estar
a un nivel deportivo tan alto
como para acudir a una cita
tan importante.
Muchos pensaban que estábamos locos,
yo misma, sin ir más lejos.
Pero confié y trabajé.
Durante mi carrera deportiva
hubo otros muchos momentos bonitos,
pero no tan intensos, tan deseados,
tan apasionantes e incluso dolorosos.
Ese día disfruté muchísimo.
Sufrí como nunca.
Me quedé vacía, sin fuerzas
ni para sostener las piernas.
Pero ese sufrimiento
me llenaba de alegría.
No quería llegar al final.
No quería cruzar la línea de meta.
Me resistía a dejar de
saborear  esa energía
que hacía vibrar cada poro de mi piel.
Toda una vida para dar sentido
a esos instantes, a esas zancadas,
a ese latir acelerado de mi corazón.
Poder saborear las lágrimas que resbalaban
por mis mejillas de forma descontrolada.
La exigencia física
se mezclaba con la satisfacción
de derrumbar la creencia de
que la maternidad puede ser un lastre
para una deportista de alto nivel.
Sé que queda mucho que trabajar para dar
visibilidad al deporte femenino.
En especial, a la capacidad real que
las mujeres tenemos después de ser madres.
Ese fue un paso adelante del que
me siento muy orgullosa.
Mis mayores éxitos llegaron
después de la maternidad.
El deporte te enseña
que se puede ser muy feliz
aún sin tener fuerzas
para levantarte del suelo.
Te puede dar un placer inmenso,
un dolor insoportable de piernas.
Puedes sentir que el final merece la pena
si durante el camino
has hecho lo correcto
y has puesto toda tu energía
en llegar ahí, a la línea de meta.
La última lección que me dio mi maestro
tiene mucho que ver con todo esto.
Me hizo entender que el deporte es
mucho más que un estilo de vida,
tener un cuerpo bonito, un poco más sano.
La vida empieza cuando nacemos.
Ahí nos ponen en una línea
de salida imaginaria,
desde donde tenemos que ir avanzando,
subiendo y bajando montañas,
sorteando obstáculos hasta que
un día nos toque llegar al final.
Nadie sabe cuándo va a llegar al final.
Pero lo que sí sabemos
es que llegado ese día,
querremos que sea con nuestra vida
repleta de éxitos y de momentos bonitos.
A partir de ese momento,
lo material carecerá de valor.
Y es que cuando uno cruza
esa línea de meta,
lo realmente importante es, precisamente,
lo mucho que hemos disfrutado.
Lo que hemos aprendido.
Los momentos que nos han hecho felices.
Lo que en realidad todos desearemos
es llegar al final de
nuestra vida exhaustos,
vacíos, doloridos pero felices.
Tener la sensación de haber exprimido
el tiempo al máximo
y que el verdadero premio, a tantos años
de superación, sea el marcharse cansado.
Muy pero que muy cansado
y con una sonrisa en nuestra
cara que delate nuestra plenitud.
La misma que se siente
al cruzar una línea de meta.
Esa última lección me la dio mi maestro.
Ese genio al que unos llamaban loco
y al que mis hijos llamaban abuelo.
Además de mi suegro, era el gran jefe.
Con nuestra mirada y nuestra locura
formábamos retos constantes.
Cuando le tocó partir, lo hizo
como no podía ser de otra manera:
con el deporte en su mente
y como compañeros de viaje,
los éxitos de los que hemos tenido
la suerte de ser sus pupilos.
Ahora que ya no corro a nivel profesional,
utilizo todo lo aprendido
fomentando el deporte en esta ciudad.
Ahora soy yo la maestra, la jefa.
Mi prioridad es la de transmitir
de la mejor forma posible
lo que aquí os estoy contando.
También he aprendido a valorar
lo feliz que puede ser ayudando a otras
personas a conseguir sus objetivos.
Ahora sé que las lágrimas
de mi familia y amigos,
cuando me veían cruzar una línea de meta,
eran una prolongación de mi alegría.
Ellos eran partícipes de mi felicidad.
Ellos también saben reconocer
que el verdadero éxito
no está en el resultado,
sino en el interior de
cada uno de nosotros.
Quiero que las mujeres sigan soñando
después de la maternidad.
Que luchen por sus objetivos.
Que podamos sentir
que el esfuerzo vale la pena.
Que la huella futura que dejemos a
nuestros hijos sea precisamente ésta.
El deporte es una escuela de valores,
donde lo principal es creer en
uno mismo y no rendirse nunca.
Por mucho que nos llamen locos,
quién sabe si detrás de esta locura no se
esconde un genio como lo fue mi maestro.
El éxito se comparte.
Nace en nuestro interior
y se alimenta de pasión.
Jamás seremos lo suficientemente
viejos para dejar de soñar,
ni tampoco demasiado jóvenes como para
no poder marcarnos objetivos ambiciosos.
Para despedirme, quiero hacerlo
de una forma especial
y necesito vuestra colaboración.
Quiero que cojáis vuestra mano derecha y
apoyéis en vuestro hombro izquierdo.
Ahora quiero que cojáis
vuestra mano izquierda
y apoyáis sobre vuestro hombro derecho.
Ahora quiero que cerréis los ojos
y penséis qué es lo que más
os ha gustado de mi ponencia.
¿Lo tenéis?
Ahora apretar fuerte las manos
contra los hombros
y recibid este fortísimo abrazo
que os estoy dando.
Al fin y al cabo, el deporte
se compone de emociones.
Y las emociones se tienen
que compartir.
Gracias.